Muzzin Kanaan is on the way to his next
customer easter is the busiest time of
the year for him Palestinian lends out
wooden cross it's a group of Egyptian
Christians are already waiting for him
he tells us that his family has been
lending out wooden crosses for nearly a
hundred years all his family are Muslims
they make a living serving Christian
pilgrims abu allah yeh our family was
designated so there wouldn't be problems
between the christian churches about who
has the right to carry the cross so a
Muslim family was chosen instead the
cannons that's my family a group of
pilgrims from Uganda is following the
Via Dolorosa the route that Jesus is
said to have taken heading for his
crucifixion there are 14 Stations of the
Cross marked out marzin Canon doesn't
charge for the crosses but he does
accept tips and donations and photos
also cost extra the group have now
reached the 9th station where Jesus is
said to have collapsed for the third
time the pilgrims two are starting to
get tired it was not very heavy because
to signify dawat e our wood went through
so I accepted it willingly
birstwith something very symbolic in my
life and my Steam this is Felicity a
group of Arab Christians from Nazareth
stopped for another quick photo before
heading for the church of the holy
sepulchre the end of the Via Dolorosa we
carry the cross to share in this
experience for ourselves that's what
Easter week is all about it takes up to
an hour to cover the route depending on
how quickly the pilgrims progress
meanwhile marcin is on his way to a
storage depot next to the fifth station
he has crosses in all sizes ranging from
15 to 45 kilos depending on how much the
pilgrim wants to suffer yannick juan
mata ji matos at Liguria some people
want a light one others heavier ones
these crosses here are medium-sized so
easier to carry but others who prefer a
heavier one get this one it's very heavy
made of olive wood and there are three
parts hello cobalt on movies you could
follow this muslin says one of the
oldest crosses has disappeared he has no
idea how the thieves managed to smuggle
it out of the country and he has no time
to sit around and wonder the next group
of pilgrims are already waiting